Inglaterra y Francia protagonizan unos
cuartos de final de lujo aquí en Qatar
2022 Los Galos de los campeones del
mundo que dejaron en el camino a Polonia
con un triunfo por tres a uno en un
partido en donde los goleadores se
quedaron con un sabor especial por un
lado Olivia llegó quien abrió la lata se
convirtió en el máximo goleador en la
historia de la selección francesa con 52
tantos por su parte kylian mbappé autor
de un doblete llegó a los cinco goles
aquí en Qatar se convirtió en el máximo
artillero de este certamen y a la vez
suma ya nueve tantos en los mundiales
superando figuras como Lionel Messi o
como a Cristiano Ronaldo por su parte el
descuento para Polonia lo hizo Robert
lewandowski que se despide de esta copa
mundo con dos goles en el otro encuentro
del día Inglaterra se impuso por 3 a 0 a
senegal en un partido en el que los
ingleses sufrieron en la en el comienzo
de la primera parte con ataques
incisivos por parte de los senegaleses y
una ocasión de oro que salvó su portero
Jordan pickford sin embargo los
dirigidos por
comenzaron a encaminar ese encuentro con
un tanto al minuto 38 de Jordan
Henderson después de una asistencia de
yout bellingham uno de los mejores sobre
la cancha antes del Descanso del turno
fue para Harry kane el delantero del
tottenham que consiguió su primer gol
aquí en Qatar 2022 después de un pase de
Phil foden para el segundo periodo para
los segundos 45 minutos bucayos acá puso
el tres a cero definitivo bocayo saca
también uno de los mejores sobre la
cancha así las cosas franceses e
inglesas se van a volver a ver las caras
en una copa mundo por tercera ocasión ya
lo hicieron en Inglaterra en 1966 y
también en España en la copa mundo de
1982 en ambas ocasiones con Victoria
para los británicos